it's relatively tranquil in the
rainforest in the south of the Central
African Republic that hasn't always been
the case but the war has shifted to
other regions now guerrilla expert
Terrence foo was one of the few people
who remained in xanga Sangha after the
area was overrun in 2013 when the rebels
got here the loot at the project site
there were some poachers that came from
Sudan and succeeded to get here went to
the zanga by West forest clearing and
killed a lot of other elephants when a
series or this place was just almost
inhabitable the unique wildlife in
Sangha Sangha is still thriving thanks
in part to generous financial support
particularly from Germany some 2000
gorillas still live in the park for the
most part undisturbed
it's a source of income for the
population we have a staff of 60 people
I'm the small village like this
employing 60 people it's not an easy
task it's like feeling like a hundred
and twenty different families so we
think that the people already benefit
from it more than 1200 wild elephants
also live in Zhuang gazonga in the
middle of the rainforest is a clearing
the animals are attracted to the mineral
salts in the soil for the past year
Louise Aran's has been working here for
the World Wildlife Fund for Nature he's
had many years of experience dealing
with nature conservation in crisis
regions elephants are a favorite target
for poachers
Aran's has spent 37 years working as a
conservationist in Africa and during
that time he's observed how elephants
are gradually disappearing from the
continent the last elephants on traffic
is here we where we are the rest of the
countries and the porches have finished
with all of them and we know that in the
future they will come here and they will
try to locate our elephants so we have
to be ready to defend us from them even
though Rangers patrol the park they
don't have enough weapons and
ammunitions to ward off the professional
poachers the situation is similar in the
rest of Africa there are a lot of people
and at least the problem that people
buying I buried they think that's only
the elephant's are dying but a lot of
people porches and Ranger for that
during previous posts in Chad and
northern Congo Aaron's lost nearly 40
employees in the battle against poachers
always the problem with the guns and
ammunition and everybody say no how do
you want against an ammunition to
protect the elephant I don't want guns
to protect the elephant I want guns to
protect the people that don't protect
the elephants that is different because
the portal can with guns if our Ranjha
have no gun they are going to die today
the locals are celebrating the opening
of a small Centre for handicrafts Louisa
runs has come to watch the dancing and
share the villagers hopes for the future
of the Sangha Sangha region
[Applause]